Batch, batch, batch!
It's really all you hear
the networking folks
ramble on about nowadays.
Almost like they're trying
to tell you something.
My name is Colt McAnlis, and
well, the truth is, they are.
We all know that
networking is the biggest
offender when it
comes to battery
drain on mobile devices.
I mean, consider the cellular
radio in any of your phones.
After a request,
it'll still wait
around for about an
extra 20 to 60 seconds,
keeping the chip awake,
drawing power just
in case a server
response comes in.
If nothing comes in, only
then will it go back to sleep.
And in the super
worst case scenario,
your app can end
up in a position
where each one of
its network requests
wakes up the cell
radio and pays the cost
to keep it awake over time.
Batching is the ideal way
to coalesce these requests
together so you only have
to pay the wake up and keep
alive penalties once.
But the big question
here is, how do you go
about actually doing batching?
Well, first understand
that any requests that
are generated as a result
of a user action, generally
need to be handled right now.
Everything else though,
is completely fair game.
Basically, if there is
even a slight chance that
delaying a request
won't cause the user
to throw their phone
out the window,
then you should
be considering it.
Now from a code
perspective, the easiest way
to implement batching is
to basically intercept
any outbound requests and
rather than executing them
immediately, store them in a
pending list of actions to be
made in the future.
This could be simple as a
queue object or as complex
as a content provider
for serializing them
to disk in case you're
worried about them getting
lost when the app is terminated.
But here is the tricky part.
How do we know when to send
these pending requests?
Well, you could just wait
until some threshold has
been reached-- like 10
requests or something--
and then purge your
list, waking up the radio
and sending out the data.
Which is a completely fine
way to approach the problem.
But the truth is the system
is doing a ton of other things
in the background,
and chances are
that before your
threshold is reached,
the cellular radio will
be turned on in order
to complete some other task.
Therefore, it makes
a lot of sense
to try and piggyback these
operations when they happen.
Basically, you can
set up this code
to give your app
a callback anytime
the networking hardware
has been fired up.
When this happens, go ahead
and purge your pending queue.
But things might get a little
bit more complex than that.
So what if you want to
wait until you're on Wi-Fi
or plugged into a power source?
Or something crazy,
like you want
to wait until the user isn't
riding a bike or in a car
anymore.
This is exactly why you need
to use GCM network manager.
This is a Google
Play services API
which helps to schedule
network oriented tasks
and handle batching for you.
This greatly simplifies
the implementation
of common patterns
such as waiting
for networking connectivity,
network retries and backoff.
Basically, all the
good stuff you need
with one single helpful API.
Now, if you don't know what
your request profile looks like
or you're in a bad spot, check
out the networking monitor tool
inside of Android Studio.
This tool will help
you see how often
inbound and outbound
requests happen
and the size of each request.
Batching is one of the
fundamental techniques that
can improve your application
performance for users,
but it's not the only networking
technique you need to know.
Which is why you need to check
out the rest of the Android
Performance Patterns content
and don't forget to join
the Google+ community as well.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember--
perf matters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]